Lila Alba Logan I think most of you know
me and I'm the director of the center
for the study of social difference and I
wanted to welcome you to what has become
something of a tradition in the last
couple of years and started last year
when I was away and that's a series of
round table conversations on keywords
and we try to draw participants together
from a wide range of disciplinary homes
and from the various centers for whom
CSSD serves as a site and support for
innovative interdisciplinary and
collaborative thinking and research
around questions of social difference
from races of class gender sexuality and
the goal of these conversations is just
to see how differently we all think
about fundamental critical concepts I
mean we could think the same way but it
hasn't worked out that way of the past
and I am really delighted that we got
such a wonderful and distinguished mix
of scholars and thinkers to agree to
come together today to offer their
thoughts on this week witness but still
very slippery concept of diversity so
thank you for joining us and being here
and i'm going to try
anything's over to Professor main I
who's a professor of history and the
lung family professor of asian-american
studies here I was agreed to moderate
and introduce and she's a US legal and
political historian who's been involved
both in cccs CSSD were changing the name
and so we're getting used to the new
acronym center for the study of social
difference and the Center for the Study
of ethnicity and race for years she's
someone interested in questions of
immigration citizenship and nationalism
she's been involved in a CSSD project on
borders and boundaries and has been a
great intellectual and political
presence here at Columbia she's the
author of many articles and books and I
loved the titles of your books and now
I'm going to go read them one of them
was called impossible subjects illegal
aliens in the making of modern America
and the lucky ones one family and the
extraordinary invention of Chinese
Americans and she's now working on
yellow and gold said still the case the
chance of working on it you'll learn
about it yes my love you do come out
with somebody
right but it could have come out already
and she be on to the next one yellow and
gold the Chinese my need I asked for
1848 to 1908 about chinese gold miners
in the North American West Australia and
South Africa which sounds amazing so
people thank you welcome friends another
one of our key words meetings these have
been great conversations so we mean to
have a brief 12 minutes or so comment
that we can really have a discussion
with everybody i think i think these the
series has been one of the great things
about CC in the hang of it is um I've
been to several of these I spoke at
making the first one we did last year on
ethnicity and nobody could agree on
anything about ethnicity when at man
drew if it was even useful and then I
remember the one I came to a movement
where we had people talk about social
movement
dance caller talk about bodily movement
so I'm sure we will have a wide-ranging
comments on the concept of diversity so
I'm just going to introduce a lot you
know I'm sure you all read in today's
times you know it was an article about
the upcoming supreme court case Fisher
vu university of texas on where they're
going to kill whatever we have left i
think on diversity so so very timely so
i'm just going to give a short
introductions to each of our speakers
they go do them all together so we can
just keep in a flow we chance to order a
little bit so we can give professor
Harris it's time to catch his breath so
first bigger will be urvashi bod who's
director at the law school of the
engaging tradition project at the Center
for gender and sexuality law it's an
exciting project that seeks to
understand how the idea of tradition
maybe that would be good keyword I'm
going to do tradition of a very sweet
but worth it okay good well either there
is used how tradition is used by and
used against movements for gender and
sexual justice in to explore how
tradition based practices inform enable
and or limit the work of these movements
avadh is former executive director of
the arcus foundation she was deputy
director of governance and civil society
at Ford and former executive director of
the National Gay and Lesbian Task Force
where she worked in various roles for
over 10 years and she's also former
prisoners rights lawyer she's the author
of virtual equality the mainstreaming of
gay and lesbian liberation creating
change public policy sexuality and civil
rights and the fan she's coming out with
a book this year irresistible revolution
that's great title confronting race
class and the limits of LGBT politics
she's graduated faster and northeastern
school of law professor Fred Harris is
professor political science and the
director of Institute of research in
African American Studies here at
Columbia he works on American politics
with a focus on political participation
social movements religion and politics
political development and afro american
politics he's written something within
religion in african-american political
activism an award-winning book and also
co-author of another award-winning book
with Valeria sand clear Chapman and
mckenzie countervailing forces in
african-american civic activism he's now
working on a book project on the
implications of the Obama candidacy for
black politics tentatively titled the
price of a ticket ok
look forward to that tina this one
really hard to work in contemporary
issues coming out in june oh good a time
for me electric sales right ok I told
this in olathe laughter guys reelect
marketers he wanted to come out yeah ok
an IRA Katznelson is professor of
political science and history he works
on comparative politics portable theory
and political and social history he has
too many books for me to read to you
here his most recent are liberal
beginnings making a republic for the
moderns and when affirmative action was
white and untold history of racial
inequality in 20th century America and
he's now completing fear itself a book
on American democracy from the New Deal
to the Cold War and liberal reason a
collection of essays on the character of
modern social knowledge ok so we'll
start with purpose sheet and about 12
minutes and I'll wave which when you
read all that busy
thank you thank you me know thank you
everybody oh go up there yes I'm sorry
for the informal conversation all right
we'll have it later well thank you for
this opportunity it's really an honor to
be with two people who are bred and
admire so much so it's fun to be an
activist in an academic setting you get
to pose in a way that you never get to
an infectious world no I mean I mean it
it's a it's been really wonderful to be
here so every time I sat down to think
about today's topic I found myself
impatient and irritated and avoiding
doing anything to write about it and I
realized that the word diversity
actually annoys me a great deal and it
even infuriated me to the point that I
couldn't focus on this exercise you know
they say if it's hysterical its
historical so I had to ask myself why
this annoyed reaction and I came up with
two reasons first my experience where
the deployment of diversity leaves me
cynical about its function and its
utility and second because too often the
deployment of the concept serves to
contain and marginalize and co-opt or
other wives absorb the challenge being
made by those outside the mainstream so
my experience with diversity comes out
of a range of situations running
nonprofits building organizations
building teams of staffs and volunteers
and in organizing projects and campaigns
and social movements and demonstrations
it comes out of funding initiatives on
diversity in philanthropy it comes out
of working in advocacy organizations on
public policy and writing public policy
and legislation working on media
fundraising
context in each of these environments
I've used the diversity argument myself
many times to question and push for
change in the dominant hierarchies of
race or gender class or sexual privilege
that I encountered in the environments
in which I was working my irritation
comes out of a frustration with the
concept as a mechanism for achieving
structural change it also comes out of
living with the backlash that any
politics that prioritizes race or
forward for grounds race springs in
America and you know what makes my
feelings about diversity so personal I
suppose is that the myriad experiences
that I've had through an accident of
birth and a chosen leftist politics of
embodying diversity and feeling used and
managed by it as a concept and an
analytic tool whether it's the
experience of being the Indian immigrant
in a small upstate town in the mid-60s
facing the question of whether you lived
in a teepee or the experience of being
an out lesbian happened 1966 by the
experience of being an out lesbian in
the ACLU in the early 80s which had a
hard time at that time seeing sexual
preference as it was called as anything
bigger than a matter of a First
Amendment issue or whether it was the
experience of being one of the only
people of color leaders that has so far
served in the mainstream LGBT movement
and I've done it for over two decades or
being the only woman in so many tables
of money privilege at decision making
tables in the day
they're in philanthropy the fact of not
being part of the mainstream is a
constant and unrelenting lesson in other
pneus and other misc gets boring and
weary especially if you think of
yourself as universal and what passes as
universal as a clever magic trick so
three ways I've used the term in my work
at first I've used it as a moral appeal
diversity is a good thing I've used it
to persuade those in the dominant group
in any particular institution that race
or gender or economic issues or
sexuality or disability should be part
of the agenda i framed it as an appeal
to do the right thing the institution
the government the corporation should do
the right thing in terms of inclusion of
difference because the exclusion or
prejudice is wrong i framed it as a todd
gitlin esque common humanity appeal
diversity is not about having one of
each at the table but knowing that we
can carry the interests of each and one
each and ourselves i framed it as an
appeal to move beyond identity it's
about a politics of justice not about an
identity X Y or Z and a justice politics
creates avenues for participation and
for recognition for a wide range of
people and lately I've been making the
case in the LGBT movement from a very
database social science nerd kind of
argument saying because there's race and
class and gender diversity in LGBT
communities we need to have a political
agenda that reflects and represents
people that we
to represent its various social science
but it works for people a second way
I've worked with the concept is to focus
on the development of tools trainings
mechanisms to increase representation
and inclusion particularly by race but
also by gender and sexuality in class on
the decision-making bodies of Ford's of
staffs of institutions we used it for
example in the 1993 march on Washington
the LGBT movement had a requirement of
fifty percent people of color diversity
on all decision-making bodies and it was
structured all these marches are crazy
processes that are fun to organize but
insane because they are so fresh fruits
and so the process of getting fifty
percent racial diversity in Iowa North
Dakota was fascinated and and soundly
criticized as you can imagine because
people in those states that this isn't
representative of us but I've also used
that in on boards and just for your
information today in the national
movements largest 40 organizations
gender parity is at about thirty percent
of boards of mice are forty percent of
national boards and those 40
organizations over
so it's not fifty-fifty and people of
color is probably in the mid thirties
I've used it in diversity trainings of
boards we've philanthropy as you all
know has invested tons in the question
of how to diversify institutions but the
Urban Institute in 2009 noted that
California which has fifty eight percent
people of color in its population that
it's nonprofits have twenty eight
percent of people of color on the board
and it nationally about fourteen percent
of board members of nonprofits are
people develop this is a 2009 state I've
used it the third way to that I've use
diversity is this ecosystem approach
that diverse organizations like
biodiversity make life better and make
all of our work more successful and
there's four key elements to that that
were nicely outlined by Jan macerata is
a fabulous thinker about nonprofit
issues based in California and she you
know summarizes that the four main
arguments we use to urge diversity and
boards is it matters as part sometimes
it matters to the organization's mission
if there's a business case to be made
it's good for business for the company
that's like that it's part of the social
responsibility of an organization and
then often if an organization strives to
serve a diverse population expect to
have that diversity and the more again
the data disprove this disprove that
this kind of
is working because we really haven't
diversified many of the nonprofit's so I
want to conclude I just talked about
three unintended consequences that these
experiences have produced that leave me
feeling the uneasiness that I started
out with I think a focus on inclusion
can actually serve to bleach out a real
power analysis second problem is that I
think a focus on adding race or
including even treats difference as if
it were a condiment Ava and German third
is that the approach you know has the
effect of reham powering that which it
says it claims to question and then the
final thing that I want to mention
actually is that is the whole question
of the backlash so diversity is bleach
right same things like we've got to
build more diversity in our board
actually can leave the conversation
about power in those institutions quite
an address you can after all add board
members by race and gender and class is
still keep the mechanisms by which power
is held and gained and distributed and
organized inside any institution intact
and it meant in my experience diversity
can become a lovely cosmetic for an
institution to say to cover structural
imbalances and how decisions are really
made and it I say bleaches out a
structural power analysis by enabling
things to become focused on identity
rather than on material things which are
part which connected to identity but not
only about identity like money what
neighborhood you live in what school you
went to who your mentor is worrying
whether they're popular what social
capital you have what social networks
your part of that's what really does
that you know like four
example philanthropic decisions are made
a lot of those kinds of factors there
really are even at wonderfully
professional organizations like the Ford
Foundation social capital matter it
matters so much more than the idea
you're walking in the door way they r
amendment that
at the same time a focus on diversity
and seeing it as inclusion can bleach
out the different histories that
different forms of exclusion brain so we
have a black president but the racism
with which he and his family are
regarded and reported and treated
reflects the persistence of ideas and
logics of white supremacy in America
both exists diversity and inclusion
programs in corporate America are great
examples of this bleaching effect
corporate diversity programs proclaim a
commitment to workplace equity within
institutions but those institutions
maintain their gender and racial
hierarchies and there's a huge amount of
literature and about the investment of
corporations on how to engage inclusion
and catalyst and all the different data
that's collected on workplace inclusion
talk about how wonderful it is but you
look at the corporate boards there are
only still sixteen percent women and you
know out an equal is this huge project
in the gay and lesbian community to do
corporate diversity work and
corporations and it's one of the largest
networks that exist again
LGBT corporate employee resource groups
they're called but I can only name maybe
one or two openly gay people in any
board or a company that's really taking
the position on gay rights issues
diversity is flavor you know what I'm
talking about I don't even have to go
into that it's like a flavor enhancer a
spice and add to the flavor of the
colonizing powers palate diversity as a
reinforcing the non-diverse category
it's a little bit like the word
privilege which i also have a problem
with you may have talked about it
because privilege feels like on the one
hand you're talking that feels
inauthentic because we're talking about
privilege but hey we're also saying we
have something it's called privilege
that we're trying to undo I feel like
diversity restates that there is a norm
against which the thing that's being
identified as different is in fact
different and it perpetually relegate
that difference to a marginal space
rather than as the main event and I have
problem that as I said earlier I think
always that in fact so diversity and
resentment a final point and they'll sit
down it would be incomplete to talk
about diversity today without thinking
about the backlash that all of our
efforts to change structural racism and
gender inequality and sexual in class
hierarchies have produced there are
serious movements that are pushing back
against all of our efforts and gene
Hardesty from political research
associates nicely named that mechanism
by which right-wing populism works as
mobilizing resentment and I like that
phrase because it captures a lot about
how the right effectively uses it but it
begs consideration of the deeper
political challenge for movements which
is the challenge of resentment that
visceral common combination of longing
and envy and anger and agreement that
comes out of feelings of loss of power
and control feelings or experiences of
humiliation experiences of losing ground
and capitalism experiences of violence
whatever that many different kinds of
people feel that leave them the field
resentment that somebody else getting
ahead when they are losing ground and I
think that as movements we really have
to not just look at the rights effective
mobilization of resentment but think
about how we ourselves respond to that
resentment for that sense of the
emergence of some people as a
suppression of others my favorite one of
my favorite poets said it best June
Jordan she said there is difference and
there is power and who has the power to
terms that determines the meaning of the
difference and so that's why I guess I
focused on power more than diversity and
that feels a more hopeful place to
intervene and focusing on the processes
by which we can organize power and
probably that's why I'm such a lesbian
feminist as I focus on process I follow
Jesus again for coming in so late I had
put this on my calendar for for this
only Sharon Harris who's the Secretary
of the Institute call me and say where
are you I said well working on
is that what you should get here now
because it's starting so unfortunately
my comments won't be as as yours but I
want to speak on a couple of things
first I do work on the black political
experience so the idea of diversity
doesn't really frequent to my work and
in a very sort of concrete way but it's
mostly historical and it's surrounded
out issues of social movement and social
change and how I communities have been
very instrumental in that change and so
when I thought about this topic I really
thought about sort of the lexicon of
change of difference of racial
difference and so if we were having this
conversation 40 years ago we wouldn't
use a concept diversity we will be
talking about desegregation or
integration which to me really talks
about institutional transformation our
institutional change and so over time as
as the country has become increasingly
diverse and also because of new
claimants are particularly adopting some
of the language and the legal strategies
of the 19
1960s like the brown decision 1964 Civil
Rights Act where in addition to race
there was also color religion and its
many no gender was thrown in initially
as a joke and there was a rallying round
including it as a protected category and
of course 1965 civil rights five so over
time you know we've gotten from you know
institutional change from integration
desegregating institutions to what you
say is this which I love this is a
bleaching of difference and so I don't
talk more detail about that but actually
I want to go to an anecdote to think
about what we need to
diversity and so last fall was one of
the greatest challenges I've had in
quite a while it was trying to get my
for you about four and a half year old
kid into kindergarten in New York City
and so you know you go to a lot of work
you know
the good public schools and go to the
independent schools and they're all
these philosophy you know brochures
about diversity and you know lots of
brown colored faces on
on the brochures and you go on on the
you know the tours and people are
talking about sort of diversity and so
when you actually look into the
classrooms and you know see who's
teaching they're not a lot of people who
look like me and myself i'll just put it
that way and so in many ways is it's
it's to me when we talk about diversity
within some context it's almost like a
publicity campaign sort of thing where
you know it's just something that you
have to go as a part of the trademark or
the brand of the organization and so it
sort of raises questions particularly
looking at it from this historical
context the question I begin to ask in
this very personal way is that who is
diversity really for right is it for
those who are trying to you talk about
powered maintain power and it's
something nothing you know my son and
I'm
sonic diversity we do want difference
but it seems that we're getting back at
least within this context in this very
personal way of this experience in New
York a situation of like 1954 you know
you know you know when the idea was sort
of integration desegregation and so I
won't name the school so we got into you
know very good school in New York and
and I went to you know the parents lunch
in
a hundred people there and the people
the parents certainly didn't look like
demographics of New York and in fact
when I looked around there was only
other one other person group of a
100 people it was very disheartening and
so you know in their class that comes
into part of this you know I can tell
but the people are very fluent yeah I
decided not decided he was real good for
one of those hairy then also it's just
forty thousand dollars but you know it's
quite a challenge for a college
professor at least this one and so so um
so yes it's these power dynamics and so
diversity for whom why tryna diversity
and so I think these are sort of the
challenging issues that we face not only
when it comes to Kenan gardens by what
it also comes to things like what kind
of representation and difference we have
in places like global
for instance on this canvas and so I
just want to leave you with this thought
these are sort of my sound a little bit
ruined but this is what I had pulled to
right out much more succinctly at my
fork laptop so also with that
well first thanks for having me it's a
delight to be honest on this panel with
colleagues so far not over the word I
disagreement I have one story to tell I
hadn't planned on but it flows from this
and it's I'm older than fretted by twin
a 31 year olds were four and up again
we're at the kindergarten stage and i
will name the school because a long time
ago was the Dalton School and we had
just moved to New York and we looked at
Bank Street look number of schools and
someone said well the best academic
school in Manhattan is dull so off we
went and very elegant it was holiday
December seasoned beautifully decorated
oriental rug on the floor and a almost
the caricature of a 1850 version of dome
of interviewed us and after the
interview i said at the end of the
interview would do she has to have any
questions and i say
might you say something about diversity
she leaned forward and said well we have
many more children now from the west
side and I understood that meant people
like me fortune which was a not part of
the tradition so diversity is a is a
word a capacious haphazard slack term on
its own with little clarity or rigor
except in context and in situation and
the question is how to think about
diversity in situation here's a
definition of diversity that I took off
the web from the University of Oregon
it's headline definition of diversity of
the continent the concept of diversity
encompasses acceptance and respect it
means understanding that each individual
is unique recognizing individual
differences these can be along the
dimensions of race ethnicity gender
sexual orientation socioeconomic status
age physical ability religious belief
political belief and other ideologies it
is the exploration of these differences
in a safe positive nurturing environment
it is about understanding each other etc
be moving beyond simple tolerance to
embrace and celebrate the rich
dimensions of diversity contained
each individual as a normative statement
it's fine unobjectionable but as an
analytical concept it's it's almost
meaningless that is to say it lists a
very long list of potential differences
among and between people a very long
list of the way in which individuals
might identify and then it says let's be
nice to each other and that seems to me
and respect each other and who would
object to that except that that's not
exactly the world in which we live a
world of hierarchies the world of power
a world of situations and it strikes me
that that simple approach and it is a
very simple approach as a kind of
normative goal is both both fine and not
very helpful on the other extreme i just
recently read some work on colonial
America of America at 1750 by richard
hofstadter and then took Veals
reflections on colonial America and then
post-independence Gustav de Beaumont on
on slavery in America and they write
about incredibly diverse country
incredibly diverse because it has a
white servitude black slavery free labor
etc diversity a extraordinary diversity
the way and religious diversity
Providence Jews of the most diverse
country on earth but that's not
diversity in the sense that the
University of our speaks of diversity so
the question is what what do we do with
this term I wouldn't give it up entirely
but I would prefer i'll make an argument
that we should prefer the verb to
diversify rather than the noun diversity
which is the state of fact of being
diverse that is is an invitation at best
the noun is an invitation to interrogate
circumstances and situations you can
have a slave plantation that's diverse
you can have University of Oregon
assuming it lives by its norms being
diverse doesn't tell you very much to
call both diverse it's an invitation to
questions and the issue is what are the
questions normatively i think in
situations that overwhelmingly tend to
be not like those as empirical matters
identified by the definition at the
university of oregon to diversify to
seek to diversify if we know what we
mean by that that is to create a
diversification not just of demography
but of capacity and I'm standing that
seems to me to be a normatively good
purpose and then we ought to ask how do
we achieve and we get from A to
in particular historical at
institutional settings as a different
kind of question than a more vague
normative goal of respect and love for
each other's differences now the so here
then for me I thought our ways of
thinking about situations because of
situations um very tough by demography
by the identities of persons compose
those populations by networks situations
are also and all networks or networks
that have relations to power that is the
capacity to identify and fashion
hierarchies and therefore on the objects
and situations of diversification bought
to be an understanding of diversity in
the sense of these dimensions of content
and boundaries of unlikeness and they
these boundaries by the way shift even
in the same place with respect to the
same populations of the example maybe a
small one but not really a small one um
as graduate student I studied among
other things matters of a color race in
Great Britain the the West Indians of
Bangladesh ease
Indians Pakistanis found in Great
Britain were all called colored image
manure Commonwealth immigrants and the
the category in which they were
considered was was race associated with
colonial experience if you go to Britain
today overwhelmingly of the asian of
migrants to do the children of those who
had come are not talking about in terms
of color at all they're talked about in
terms of religion in terms of Islam well
how does that shift happen and what is
the meaning of that ship who's that
shift generated from inside or outside
of what are its implications with
respect to standing and power what is it
one of the implications with respect to
political coalition's and possibilities
of what happened to the racial dimension
and color dimension is it no longer
important are there issues which which
do in fact bind West Indians and South
Asians together in that circumstance or
do they no longer bind them together and
so on so you have a diversity of
different kinds but the nature of
networks the nature of coalition's the
character of power the meaning of
identity all with respect to it to a
roughly stable demographic circumstance
give
and to free migration and entry are all
raised by that kind of case and these
issues of power and networks and
identity have normative implications as
well as empirical ones about the control
and ownership and meaning among other
things of space an example from research
I did a long time ago on Washington
Heights I used to ask people who is
mostly in a part that we in inwood that
was both Irish and Jewish and I found
matched blocks where roughly thirty
percent of the people lived there were
Irish in 30 and I asked people whose
neighborhood is this whose blocked is
this and you find that each block there
was a consensus is the Irish
neighborhood or this is a Jewish
neighborhood and the only thing that
really differed was the placement of
religious institutions if there was a
parish church in invisible view this was
an Irish block through the synagogue of
the Jewish block but the demography was
was identical in both but it turns out
that had real meaning political meeting
because when it came to community board
meetings and planning sessions if this
was defined as an Irish block then
Monsignor X would be the person
consulted as opposed to rabbi y and the
nature of construction and and and
meaning would be altered by virtue of
them now just
and end of time we need if we really
want to think about diversifying we have
to think about the nation the nature of
settings in which people have
experiences of diversity schools we've
talked about home work and and levels of
aggregation of space do we diversify in
a university department a school what
one of the units which we're talking
about a block a neighborhood a city a
state a whole country and and and one of
the implications of working at different
levels for questions of power the ones
that will raise the very beginning today
and then what kinds of projects are
there that can be mounted for
diversification that don't produce
bleaching about that in fact produce a
mixture of cacophony and and music and
you don't want pure music Oregon style
because that would be a very boring
world but you don't want pure cacophony
item and the question is how do we move
towards making projects for diversity
that can achieve both and I'll end by
saying what I think the right normative
goal is for at the level of individuals
and groups especially those who have
lived outside the center of some
hegemonic definitions sort of
of who counts seems to me the issue
always is to gain the same level of
choice that those at the center have
always had I II choice about how
strongly to value the particularity of
the individualizing or segmenting
identity and choice about bleaching if
you choose to and moving into those the
core institutions is if you're no
different than anybody else the central
hallmark of circumstances of oppression
are circumstances where people do not
have such choices and then the question
is how are those choices arrived at of
one of the terms of that choice and to
use a phrase talk veal of once used in
plucking back among other things
Catholics and their integration in
America how much sacrifice of bonds of
memory took million phrase is required
for entry into a world which is not
separate but let's use the old-fashioned
word which is integrated but integrated
in multiple dimensions and that's not a
simple question if you think about it in
terms of first-year students at this
unit
who come from a variety sometimes a very
diverse and sheltered environments who
have not lived with four reasons either
of choice or not the absence of choice
have not lived with people other than
people much like themselves and look
like themselves they face on a daily
basis the question of how they manage or
what what degree of repression exists to
their own particularity in order to join
a collective diversification those are
not easy questions for individuals or
four groups but having a genuine scope
for choice seems to me to be at least a
normative goal exactly and that we
should have it as a goal that cannot be
achieved without attention to the kinds
of issues people ready heard about
especially questions in Parliament and
thank you
inside we've got
a half hour to open up the discussion
I think I'll wait and just open it up
we'll come back to the panel
responses to this let me see if I can
start pulling together
so the first response i have is maybe
the keyword should have been normative
as opposed to diversity because
seemed to me that
the problematic
is that whatever it is that the cold
diversity
fine against something and here I think
about Adrian which just pass that essay
though everybody women studies reads
which time I'm not blocking been about
head on over to the English and
certainly folks compulsory no compulsory
heterosexuality thank you
but you know where she evokes the notion
of heteronormativity essential
as a way of understanding what it is
oneself against it so the diversity
comes what is not normative and it
strikes me both you know listening to
Fred ask the question who is diversity
for well really in some ways it is it's
designed to maintain the normative as we
use it so whether it's designed to make
by reaching out the different
whether it's designed to maintain it by
denying choices iris says it does seem
to me that one can have this
conversation without asking the question
of what sustains
now is how this power is so constructed
either around identity or around class
or whatever it is so that somehow that
becomes
the office gets itself
alrighty open I'm just the follow it's
just the same I mean it's interesting is
that you're going all everybody's got a
lot of thought yeah we're not there's no
argument here but there's something I
mean and the prevent question was why
isn't there an argument here and I think
it's perhaps o them maybe in the crowd
there is a good argument here that if we
think about the history in which this
idea of diversity emerged the history in
which the idea of diversity merchants in
the US was the history of the liberal
politics of recognition as way of
solving a systemic legitimacy crisis and
you know we can think of this globally
right so you have the anti-colonial
movements putting into crisis the
narrative of civilization as legit and
then you can use social movements and at
stake when these were if I wouldn't say
normativity I don't
transformation like fundamental
transformation of a of a system that
itself was emergent and mobile and I
think at least a lot of folks in the
front table and maybe some folks in the
back think yeah that's right and the
liberal politics recognition the shift
to tolerance of difference was a way of
reversing the problem of legitimacy that
had been addressed to liberalism as such
and turning it into a problem legitimacy
addressed to the diverse people claiming
supposedly they want to be a part of
thing or they didn't want they won't
change the table it would blow up the
table so so what surprised that
diversity has these functions it is
itself an effect of a very interesting
very massive way of solving a historical
legitimacy crisis that's absolutely 50s
60s 70s and boom in 70s after those 50s
and you can globalize it you get the 70s
and which we can start having all the
debates about tolerance word conclusion
is a level up so how do we have a
conversation about the horrible origins
of the shift how it is yeah i'm not sure
that normative with transformation or
what it is but that's what's cool
altered quotation or thought it's really
so too because it's conscious lioness
cameltoe ya know I really appreciate
this i'm actually one of the reasons we
wanted agri here was thinking about
having your talk about tolerance and i
think when we originally brought up the
idea of inviting you to be part of this
but we can use that as the key word but
I thought diversity was something that
had built into it then Oregon you see
Morgan definition is I'm beyond to be on
time so so there's that kind of
liberalism but the other thing just to
come back to things
to keep this term isn't it has had very
specific uses and institutions and I
always thought that as a euphemism
because you could talk about affirmative
action it's not legal anymore to do so
so then that word for all of those of us
who are critical of it as a term have to
use it because otherwise it's against
the wall you can't say you know we eat
up so that was my understanding when we
all sat on the Diversity Committee in
the library try and figure out what to
do here that nobody believed it as
tolerant or inclusion but here was the
way to change the institution and this
was the only tool we had now that was
legitimate and the trustees might give
us one millions of dollars for ya so
there's some so that's the situatedness
of the term and you've seen its
integrated
you know each of you about how it's this
way so I want I really like somehow
thinking about the larger but t if we
think of it as a way which I think it's
going to do and then then it's a tool
and how do you if you think about the
children what are you doing for tool you
use the tool as it's given to your hand
to keep building a house or use jeans
Janet yeah and that's the only real
question on the table jam it or build
the house so she can learn what you can
answer any of this kind of program
including but not limited to this but
the question again is the that's meant
how many tools you have if the
foundation is still Yeah Yeah Yeah right
until I make this technology Lord great
and so so you know so what are the
consequences of that right but also this
what you speak of is the politics of
recognition
very interesting is it mostly because
you know claimants from all these
diverse groups want to be recognized
right and it is very important but the
process it is the process for the
existence of recognition what sort of
ideological reinforcement it has for
those groups and also does it really
blunt their vision of what
transformation should be about because
they have the wreckage so that's I want
I just want to put down yeah
yeah I mean these are immensely
complicated rich questions of the
stomach that the question of tool just
come out
I said I preferred the verb
diversification to diversify
to diversify as a verb rather than
diversity as
as a crisp enough word to describe where
we are and then the question is what do
we mean by to diversify and then all the
issues come up including what is
normative it was so it's taxes if I
women whether with the focus and debate
ought to be it is worthless I I have a
slight reservation in too thick and
unitary a use of the word liberal and of
course not just just become embrun that
if we think from dubois through Martin
Luther King jr. and so on the the
central issue was how to secure
membership in the status of little sis
not the only thing at issue but without
Civic standing not they understood and
rightly understood that nothing else
could follow as a strategy of a power
that is to say unless you had Civic
standing unless persons had Civic
standing than exclusions from physical
space issues of physical security issues
of material rights to earn a living and
issues of cultural expression of which
challenged normative centrality and
explode the cultural category none of
that could happen that in a kind of
lexical hierarchy was critical to to
obtain Civic standing what essentially
izle is
a polity based in its ideas not in its
practice on government by consent rule
of law etc so that's not an ideological
statement that we should believe that
each of those categories is operating as
described but it is as an empirical
matter of a way to talk about critical
parts of social movements which were
incendiary in their own terms because
the membership question the very
membership question not even what
happens after you get membership but the
membership question itself was the
source of the greatest amount of
violence in American history all through
the to the present but certainly at the
at the high points of civil rights
struggle or period after reconstruction
and so on something so that's a
long-winded way to just said one word
about toleration tie default not
originally with defined toleration as a
circumstance i prefer toleration to
diversity as a verb as a noun the
Toleration is a circumstance where a has
power over me
we're a dislikes be and for whatever
reason a does not use its power to
inflict harm on be absent tolerant now
that's a long way from what I the world
I would like it's a long way from
anything like mutual respected
toleration let alone and change to the
normative center of things because if
you have a pnas got power but absent
toleration from the kit bag of things we
live in a in a much more horrific world
because most of the time in most places
you have lots of circumstances where A's
have power and don't like bees and they
do things to be which are a deeply
unpleasant so therefore I would not give
up the term toleration even knowing its
limits and the limits are profound but
sometimes we need a heterogeneous kit
bag of tools in order to achieve
something that looks more Johnson
I was trying to very much speak from the
experience changing trying to change
institutions and government or practices
which is where I've used the term and so
in that in those realms I think the
difference between the noun and the verb
actually while it's really interesting
doesn't work for me because to diversify
its different from reconstructing and a
lot of times what I was trying to say is
that my experience is that good projects
which have had good results in terms of
changing the compositions of staff's but
don't report haven't really treats more
than content at those groups are working
on or or you know produced courage would
be a more reconstructive project and
gets to sometimes it isn't you know much
as I'd like to be the person smashing
the table of power a lot of times you're
the person trying to just get those
tables empowered in two different day
for that's and that I really believe it
and you know it's it's possible to do
that but only if you keep a real clear
I'd focus on representation isn't enough
you know and yes we're using the Masters
tools but I don't believe in unilateral
disarmament utopian society it's
interesting that we've been using the
concept of power but I haven't heard us
talk about inequality
which i think is more specific and is as
more to do with the historical
basis of how we got from affirmative
action to diversity affirmative actions
aimed at
inequality
diversity
for whose good becomes very vague in the
back and in fact is most legally the
idea that it's good for the mainstream
to have different people around so they
got a better education rights good for
white kids to have some colored kids
because they get they get a more ruffalo
about the education so the beneficiary
or the project completely changes and
then what you do for that then doesn't
have to address structural questions
such as
the impoverishment of public school
which is why
I me either dawn enough black kids going
to college good college
you're just dumb or because there's
something wrong with the entire
educational system
you have to believe one or the other
there wasn't a lot of room for you know
I mean so I think I think what we were
stuck with this concept legally right I
think
we need to be more creative in terms of
how to
articulated in a way that gets back to
because if you can't solve the k-12
problem you know now all their dicks
find all these different
strategies to achieve diversity right
which are now
you also greater equals
but none of none of this talks about how
to improve education so you have
of footing in terms of so what you have
doesn't look like it's just compensatory
or reverse discrimination
how we can use what were the tools that
were stuck with
to push it
because the recognition stuff for the
multi-core systems
so you know it's not bad but it's
certainly not what
so bored come
i well I'm I'm an administrator so I
think my responses and it actually it's
interesting being here today because I
knew that some half the time while this
presentation was going on today it was
going to be an announcement coming out
from the president the provost office
announcing a 30 million dollar
commitment to further enhancing faculty
diversity so actually I was wondering
when would it hit for which speaker at
what moment CA was I right with my
coaches promised exactly is the
Commissaire it it is it is actually
fascinating if you hear this in good
light up the the what I think the
university is trying to do get edit very
much is what I shall should say I work a
lot with demographers to be on speed to
have to fuss idea that advisors do a
head count and
then I hear the argument very much that
you know representation is not enough I
think that's major first
but if it it feels necessary and I think
that's probably why the University
continues to to go at it and these are
not intellectual comments and the extent
of what are what are we up to here and
how do how do we how do we have to get
to this spot having to make versity
supplemental
but they there is there is and actually
as I was thinking about I think in some
ways universities are have some
differences if they're like getting more
partners on law firm that they faculty
members tenured faculty members have
some uniqueness is that other
organizations don't quite have and if
you can enhance the diversity be it by
gender by race ethnicity whatever I
can't remember how many dimensions on
the way the woodlot get that there is
that there is power in being tenured
faculty members in an institution in
it's the power at the level of local
library can go up or down on some some
basis than we recently saw it go down
pretty significantly
short term but at the level of the
faculty that feels if you just go right
it's it's it's not enough but it's sher
singh righteousness
I was a student at these numbers and
standing much higher than the median a
member of the class they were not a
cross-section of were black America the
they were in the Faculty of very few
Catholics and very few Jews even in the
early in the mid 19th mid-late 1960s so
in the sense of representation some
things do get better and change and they
are the necessary condition for leo to
the other transformational things to
happen absent that form of
representation it seems to be a hopeless
idea to think that so then the question
is what do we mean by the verb to
diversify I mean it doesn't just mean
representation it means to take up those
questions of networks at capacity an
inequality and power and but from a
basis that that has which is the
opposite of what you describe of that
rule of a hundred people and only one
other person or family like yourself it
would matter a lot if there were 15 or I
don't know what the writing is the right
number but there are threshold numbers
in which Sandra Day O'Connor knew the
number was not one well it's not the
very texture of possibilities alters now
that's a long way from from doing
for Walter no I know I'm of course yes
of course it's greater than one question
should be whatever it is yeah of course
we should put their really follows right
at all whatever it is not all in but the
point is and especially if we think is
really interesting to think about the
historical relationship between what we
call democracy liberal democracy and
what we call capitalism that was
happening at the time that the question
of just getting becoming part of a civic
becoming a civic member in the 50s and
60s was in fact a radical idea and was
strongly opposed by many off to the
country letters to the relationship
between democracy and capitalism now in
which it's increasingly queer
representation sure how about the
representation well because it does make
a damn bit of difference governments are
assigned by the markets and if you
really think they're not then look at
the El Monte and greet when push comes
to shove right and I think a lot of
people say yes on one hint sure yeah
absolutely let's keep on trying to beat
Civic members but there's also an
increasing understanding that perhaps
that form of governance relation capital
is not neither the first nor the last
step to Rupp try to rethink about right
but if you put if you get or she'd save
it in fact it may be
in other words diversity may yet fact it
hip it once so yeah that's like that
it's your shirt okay democratize
increasingly router is it so you know
they look like a boxing undercutting do
packing and the increased representation
that we do see why not enough but that
we can see in positions of leadership
corporate boards universe tenured
faculty administrators
do you think that reflects another kind
of diversity which is a kind of growing
middle class educated class we in
historically subordinated here so and
then you have a kind of palm so you do
actually have progress or increase
participation or seat at the table but
whether or not the people not in that
socio-economic position actually
actually benefit is questionable it's a
big questions right theoretically better
and worse at the same but the other than
how I analyzing have you know really
structural or to some kind of
unemployment and disempowerment and you
have I'm sorry you also have a rhetoric
that sort of says that you know these
people are captivated so why can't
exactly what Ray said so it's
post-racial right and so it doesn't
attend to sort of the structural issues
that it was concerned
and i guess i would say the university
should be applauded for doing excellence
in this space there's to change story of
absence it should be applauded for that
at the same time I wouldn't stop at the
applause because you can you can change
you can you know throw the money on the
table but where these positions going to
be who are the people who are selected
are they go along get along people are
they real change agents how much power
does the person you have you know I used
to always say to friends running
organizations that we're talking about
trying to change their boards don't just
bring on one person color bring on five
at a time in one class so that so many
people aren't like the one person we
want to Family in the room but there's
like a bunch and even its butt and bring
on people that are kind of in
relationship to each other already so
there's so many factors that you can
engineer in
creating meaningful diversity verses and
go punish formulae it yet don't punish
the spaces that actually have been doing
a good job for instance our department
that were always problem kind of for all
the pros who ever told anthropology we
can't get we couldn't get a what is it
used to be called a higher of the target
of opportunity and because we're
actually fairly pretty good actually
look around our thing so our department
won't be able to hire for the next 20
years today we won't get a normal higher
because it's frozen them and be all the
other hiring will go to departments that
are our have been very bad you that have
been good bad part of me to do things so
that's the other thing that's really
interesting why not yes that diverse to
find a place of need to be but not
punish those folks who have been working
great I'm working very alright embed
work my process no excess administrator
I want you to take that back to your
meatballs we are a part of your Palace
anyone yeah any nice i'm still so
troubled by the
supplied from one so when i look at your
department and i see ya you know you're
a girl but no what about if we thought
about class department what about
here we got to dry but say exactly red
dragon but ere are we in an a well or it
may well be that traffic to not the
issue but but it still does seem to me
that if the notion of diversifying
assumes embedded within that notion here
is a concept of what you're diversifying
from you know what and as long as that
notion is shifting sand you're playing
at and he politics with the notion of
diagnosis so you know you've got Benson
the other group and satisfy even and do
a good job of this group that group in
the other group but you still haven't
challenged the core of power if you like
care for the engine of transformation
you know I can use that parallel and
that's what bothers me about the notion
of diversity
I I shave the sin
think the word itself is a way of making
people feel
better and i don't know how i mean i can
give you a dozen sort of hook so you
know i'm a kid a child of a refugee
family in wartime Britain and as we like
two brothers and I tiny children three
four five six years old walk down the
street there the kids are throwing
stones at us literally don't send dogs
on us we don't look different but we
speak in the different
language I mean you know where what's
the diversity right with diversifying
from what look the same we
we educated parents and they had over
they don't they're you know we
stand up you know in other words
they're the same
language divides and I'm I'm thinking
that how do you you know how would our
conception you know
normal
using it
such as slippery
notion
and I think when universities use it
they use
hope not soon
I think what's up bringing up idol
comedy thing like breaking up is some
sort of question of to what end is all
of this happening
say yeah terrific but and I think that
that's why I see I think the more
interesting places to focus our on
questions of
what some people would call the end
state of all of our work and how you
create construct processes that enable a
lot of different kinds of people to
promote their own vision of that end
state grows another form of diversity
that's often disparaged and that's why
you're the routine I see the smile but
vibrant work I get it but i'm still
using it because i'm trying to find
mechanisms as an organizer to encourage
maximum input into that end state the
other thing I'll say is Sarah random
points there is no perfect state of
diversity or inclusion my partner Kate
and I often joke that our favorite most
lasting auditory memory of the 1970s and
be feminists in 1970s and lesbian
feminist is the sound of folding chairs
widening in a circle opening inclusion
of it right always and why being a
circle and that was such a focus that
that became the focus and you can see it
in the LT boxy movement where you're
constantly widening a circle with the
names LGBTIQ a bit and i love that i
actually there's a profound acceptance
of that kind of consciousness that there
will always be somebody coming in the
room going but what about me and I like
that you want to create that space you
want to have that person feel empowered
in the room to be able to stand up and
say what about me you want to have them
we heard which is the recognition part
no I'm not for revision oh well I'm
saying I am
you can't add without you as long as
you're fine that's this is going to
extinguish this vision I but always
plural eyes and I just think it's a
little bit is sick final point is it
then that brings me to the problem that
I have with it is my own vision is then
there are people who are always feeling
excluded so this that whole thing about
resentment
politically as a social movement person
I then figure out how to deal with
resentment of those people who are
feeling pushed by my presence
not to throw in something else what I
was struck by something Tyra said
earlier in his talk about the bonds of
memory and until Phil which I
interpreted as I'm not sure that one has
to give up memory in order phil was
reporting that groups in America like
American Catholics who he said were far
more accepted in Protestant America and
they were in Protestant Europe were
Catholics have been killed I mean war
between Protestants and Catholics but
that had that had meant implicitly that
American Catholics were going to move
their Catholicism closer to
Protestantism than was true in the
European continent but there was a price
to be paid being what he called bonds of
memory and so you end up with let's
quote a more liberal Church or
Protestant church then was true in the
center of Europe at the same time and
from Tocqueville's point of view that
was a net plus because in France in the
19th century the conflict between
Republicans and Catholics was such that
it was a war of all against all and he
saw that in America adjustments made
mutually we're creating a terrain in
which campus could continue to be
Catholics but they weren't the same
Catholic
and the Protestants were at the same
price but that also raises deep
questions about the eraser or anything
different yeah right right but not only
difference but something that may raise
a moment ago about the groups within the
group within the groups who have games
recognition and that how does memory
play within that context for them and
particularly when you think of the
nation-state how their memory gets
interpreted as part of the national
memory and how does the national memory
articulate sort of what's happened with
the group and has come from where it has
and so on what that has on sort of
social movements
for change to continue if that erase
your tapes and so this this is part of
the price the consequences
especially when we have
eliza market economy
the guy de thoses
okay laughs you did the last word that's
privileged report seems to me that that
they're just two points first let's not
assume that that all the trouble is all
the problems lie with those with a lot
of power always or in dominant positions
we live in a world where civil society
often transmits through the very
mechanisms of voting public opinion
journalism article quite ugly things a
anti diversity that is to say it's not
as if American 300 million people in
American society the right number is a
role a lusting for a equal recognition
of diversity and so on then there's
there's trouble in the world which
sometimes people with authority have to
grapple with and they do it for better
or for worse so I think it's a just
we've talked about at all about the what
it looks like bottom up right now and
the pressures political mobilizing
social movement pressures sometimes on
the right which are very powerful
and if anything even self consciously or
anti diversity and for strengthening
normative privileges a second and last
thing I want to say is that verb for
individuals and groups who experience
life at the frontiers of inclusion and
potential capacity to demand
transformation three sets of issues
seems to me and this would be true of
the 19th century immigrants as well as a
racialized minorities today face very
similar puzzles one is the bonds of
memory question which is what what kinds
of choices are required in order to
enter whether it's a dress speech of a
cultural expression in networks in
friendship patterns and so on there's a
second set of question which has to do
with responsibility or feelings of
responsibility for those who were in
that know from the same look like you
but and what the same background is you
but not even come close to the frontier
of entrance what what if anything is the
degree of responsibility and that set of
issues and it's anxiety of charge set of
issues it doesn't go
and and third are a set of issues for
those even more distant that is to say
how far does one's identity geography
extend is adjust for the group in this
country or this university or what have
you um or is it is it national or is it
global um what does it mean for a second
generation Mexican in California or
Arizona what are the what's the sense of
connection or obligation not just the
people in California who are not at the
threshold but people on the other side
of the border and which borders in
Europe work for example on on the global
networks and movement
people often sharing the same occupation
but in very different places raises all
those questions about what constitutes
the the scope and networks of a wider of
set of responsibilities and
relationships and those questions don't
go away those are permanent questions
they'll be permanent no matter what
degrees of successful transformation we
arrive at because we'll never have it
all or nothing solution
I like that little switch and I think as
as scholars as well as citizens then be
attentive to those and try to think
harder about them in a way which then
gives guideposts for people who want to
think in their own lives about how to
want the repertoire of options we don't
but thank you for